[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia en foco su
programa sobre la actualidad francesa en
esta edición nos encontramos aquí en la
Plaza de la Concordia y donde está este
famoso obelisco este monumento que llegó
aquí en parte Gracias a John polio quien
lo descubrió durante su viaje a Egipto y
durante unos 200 años este monumento ha
sido la prenda de amistad entre Francia
y Egipto a lo largo de este programa
hablaremos de este historiador y
filólogo francés quien descifró ya hace
200 años la piedra de roseda hablaremos
de su vida su obra y su legado
y de la Plaza de la Concordia nos
internamos aquí en el Museo de Lugo para
hablar de la vida de ronçois El que
nació en el sur de Francia pero pasó
buena parte de su vida en y fue allí
donde su hermano mayor se convirtió en
su mentor y sobre todo quien le inculcó
el interés por la arqueología
que en 1790 en una familia de siete
hermanos su padre Tenía una librería y
fue más una figura ausente es un polión
se dice que fue un genio a los cinco
años aprendió a leer solo fue su hermano
mayor Jackson quien decidió encargarse
de su educación para eso lo trajo a
vivir cerca algo noble en esta casa que
hoy es un museo
al parecer El pequeño shampollón
desarrolló su pasión por las leguas
Orientales en la biblioteca de su
hermano a los 10 años quiere aprender
hebreo luego árabe y Ciriaco y arameo a
los 14 estudia el copto que será clave
para descifrar los jeroglíficos y desde
1805 se apasiona por Egipto que al
parecer habría propiciado la amistad que
su hermano tiene con el prefecto de
eliseaf Quien fuera miembro de la
expedición de Egipto a pesar de que son
polígono fuera un niño ávido de
aprenderse distraía fácilmente en este
salón en medio de retratos familia eres
ambos hermanos pasaban tiempo juntos a
la un sexeta Jackson se sabe que era un
niño un poco turbulento muy curioso con
ganas de aprender Y que su hermano mayor
que ven Justo a mis espaldas debía
canalizar y guiar es Bajo su dirección
que el pequeño shampollón va a
desarrollar ese gusto por el Antiguo
Egipto ya de joven sigue muy apasionado
por sus estudios sus investigaciones un
temperamento Franco firme y a veces
emite juicios un tanto feroces sobre sus
contemporáneos se sabe que era muy
irónico
para esa época la civilización egipcia
fascinaba y Esto fue fundamental para
los descubrimientos de chomporio
los dos hermanos son pollón crecen en un
período durante el cual el Antiguo
Egipto está de moda tras la gran
expedición de Egipto dirigida por
Bonaparte 167 sabios acompañan esta
expedición y estudia todos los aspectos
de este territorio la fauna la flora los
monumentos las antigüedades la geografía
todo este conocimiento será publicado en
la descripción de Egipto de 1809 a 1829
por eso se pone de moda y esto se
refleja en la arquitectura en el vestir
en los muebles todo el mundo está
fascinado por ese territorio
el descubrimiento de la piedra de
rossette en 1799 dio un nuevo impulso al
estudio de la escritura jeroglífica para
determinar si era simbólica o fonética
John es el primero en superar este
debate gracias al estudio del zodiaco de
denguera presentado aquí va a demostrar
que algunos signos no se pronuncian sino
que son un calificativo de los que le
preceden y establece un alfabeto
fonético basado en la piedra de Rosetta
y demuestra que la escritura jeroglífica
es fonética y simbólica el 14 de
septiembre de 1822 rompolión cayó
exhausto tras su hallazgo su hermano
reunió todas las informaciones del
trabajo y impacto a la famosa carta
anuncio de asíe que sería presentada a
la academia de inscripciones y letras
Esa fue la consagración para un genio
que murió a los 41 años
el estudio de las lenguas orientales a
cautivó desde muy joven y eso le
permitió entender que descifrando la
escritura jeroglífica tendría la llave a
la civilización egipcia veamos Entonces
cómo sonfolio logró desvelar este
misterio que duró oculto por más de 20
siglos
Todo comenzó en 1799 con el hallazgo de
la piedra de roseta una Estela que Data
del siglo II antes de Cristo en ella fue
tallado un decreto del rey griego de
Egipto ptolomeo quinto el texto está
escrito en griego antiguo jeroglíficos
la escritura Sagrada y escritura
demótica una versión simplificada del
egipcio antiguo una clave para el
desciframiento se obtuvo comparando los
tres textos con base en las teorías del
padre bactelemí del inglés tomación
ruffonsompolió encontró la relación
entre las letras griegas y su traducción
fonética en jeroglíficos
esto le permitió identificar los nombres
traducidos del griego ptolomeo y
Cleopatra sin embargo su método no
funcionó para los nombres en egipcio
luego de consultar otros documentos
antiguos rompolio verificó una pista los
jeroglíficos también serían ideogramas
es decir símbolos que representan una
idea o un sonido y que se combinaban
para formar palabras así fue como pudo
descifrar su primer nombre en egipcio en
jeroglífico compuesto por tres palabras
el primero representa al sol son
polígono lo asoció al sonido ra el
nombre del dios sol el segundo signo se
refiere al nacimiento y se pronuncia
micé en lengua corta el último signo
corresponde a la s deptomish por
ptolomeo que ya había sido identificado
en la piedra de roseta juntos forman la
palabra Ramsés por primera vez en 1500
años se lograba así descifrar un nombre
del egipcio antiguo escrito en
jeroglíficos pero a John Paul le
tomarían varios años más de arduo
trabajo y un viaje a Egipto en 1828 para
poder leer el texto en su integralidad
seguimos en la luz porque la historia de
esta institución está ligada ampollón de
hecho él fue el primer conservador de la
colección egipcia y para hablar un poco
más de esto nos acompaña que hay más
Regal ella es egiptóloga bienvenida
hablemos de esa fecha del 14 de
septiembre de 1822 exactamente qué es lo
que se sabe de ese anuncio cuando él
rompió dice que ha logrado el
desciframiento de la piedra de roseta
lo que sabemos de ese 14 de septiembre
de 1822 es una leyenda contada por su
sobrino en los cuenta que cuando su tío
pudo entender cómo funcionaba el sistema
de los jeroglíficos egipcios había
corrido hacia su hermano mayor gritando
Tengo mi negocio luego le habría
explicado durante largo rato que había
comprendido el sistema antes de
desmayarse cayó en una especie de coma
durante varios días Es por eso que eso
su hermano quien va a redactar el
borrador de lo que se conoce como la
carta al Señor dazié unos días más tarde
el 27 de septiembre de 1822 champolión
presenta ante la academia de ciencias y
letras esta carta al señor dacié y da a
conocer al mundo cómo logró descifrarlo
Bueno pero antes de llegar precisamente
a ese desciframiento él se apoyó en
estudios que otras personas hicieron
anteriormente Como por ejemplo John y el
hecho también que
a la escritura y ética era un digamos
una versión más sencilla de la escritura
jeroglífica cuáles fueron esos trabajos
que vinieron previamente y esto como
ayudó a fundamentar finalmente el
hallazgo posterior
de papá
se apoyó en otros trabajos como los de
formación o el padre Wagner en mí que
había encontrado en los cartuchos
egipcios nombres de Reyes partido de eso
y trabajo mucho en la escritura
jeroglífica y al mismo tiempo en las
versiones se simplificadas la escritura
demótica la escritura y erética como
podía hablar unos 15 idiomas una de
lenguas orientales y con la mezcla de
todo eso el estudio de cientos de
documentos durante unos 15 años llevó a
que pudiera entender cómo funcionaba el
sistema de los egipcios antiguos y
comprender que un jeroglífico podía
hacer varias cosas a la vez no solo un
signo sonido sino también un signo de
idea Esa fue la gran Revolución lo que
los investigadores que le precedieron no
habían logrado comprender
nadie
y finalmente este hallazgo que es un
hallazgo histórico Cómo revoluciona el
estudio de la civilización egipcia y de
otras civilizaciones e incluso Qué
impacto tiene hoy
lo efecty
el hecho de que el desciframiento se dé
en 1822 es un gran avance para la
ciencia ya que por fin se pudo
comprender tener acceso a la
civilización egipcia a través de los
textos egipcios en esa época había que
pasar por los autores griegos autores
latinos mientras que aquí se los textos
originales como fuente fue una
Revolución y sobre todo es gracias a
champoñón que se pudo entender lo que
las palabras egipcias significaban en
egipcio Y a partir de 1822 se tiene
acceso a toda o a casi toda la
civilización egipcia es una Revolución
para la ciencia
y al día de hoy eso que Qué impacto
tiene eso todavía es algo que se que se
que se refleja en los estudios que se
hacen hoy en día
disciplina para nosotros un champoleon
es el padre de nuestra disciplina hoy ya
no utilizamos la gramática de champonio
porque a pesar de que tenía buena
intuición sus manuales son obsoletos
utilizamos otros documentos Pero es el
Quién puso las bases el fundamento de
estos estudios para la escritura pero
también para la arqueología la historia
del arte bujó la arqueología y polilaga
en un chileno
su padre y otros egiptólogos tomaron el
relevo
Entonces el padre de la egiptología y al
mismo tiempo tiene una relación muy
estrecha con este lugar donde estamos en
la luz este lugar que tiene unas 50.000
piezas de esta colección de el Antiguo
Egipto Cómo trabajo él para poder ir
comenzando Ya esa esa colección unos
cinco años después de su descubrimiento
hay un lazo importante entre shampollón
y el museo de louvre porque el
departamento de antigüedades egipcias
fue creado gracias a jean-clans y a una
colección que había localizado la
colección South que llegó en 4000 cajas
al look se debía crear entonces un
departamento para acogerlas shampoo León
fue el primer conservador de este
departamento de ahí ese fuerte lazo
entre los dos y cuando chompo unión se
convirtió en conservador tenía una idea
innovadora quedaría atrás el presentar
la colección como se acostumbraba un
poco como gabinete de curiosidades sino
de presentarlas de forma pedagógica
temática y eso fue una verdadera
Revolución en esa época y es un poco el
rasgo de carácter del descifrador por el
que tengo tanta estima era un gran sabio
pero también un gran pedagogo su deseo
era transmitir no sólo a sus pares sino
también al público las cuatro salas se
crearon en esa óptica
pues alguien muy apasionado pero
finalmente su viaje a Egipto solamente
se da seis años después de de esa de ese
descubrimiento porque se tarda tanto en
ir allí y sobre todo que se sabe de ese
tiempo que él estuvo en Egipto claro
es cierto que se demora en ir solo viaja
en 1828 seguramente por cuestiones
financieras también es gracias al
gobierno italiano que decidió financia
la mitad de la expedición y luego
Francia decidió asaltar por eso fue una
expedición Franco Toscana durante esos
17 meses de viaje en Egipto champoleon
pudo verificar que su sistema funcionaba
se habla de la carta del Señor dazie de
1822 pero en 1829 le vuelve a escribir
para decirle estoy en lo profundo de
Egipto y mi sistema funciona
así que necesitaba ir a Egipto porque
era vital para él pero también para
confrontarse a los textos y verificar
que su sistema funcionaba que es un
sistema funciona finalmente todo un
sueño materializado Muchas gracias
Karina
hasta aquí esta edición de Francia en
foco Gracias por acompañarnos continúen
con nuestra programación en France 24 y
France 24.com